and what has gotten into Russia's top
athlete needles apparently but more on
that later as we yield for breaking news
Edie thank you breaking news that's
horribly tragic if your children are
watching we warn you it's graphic our
lead story tonight atop the report was
Donald Trump eating chicken with a knife
and a fork Plus this Trump supporter is
11 years old so what are his thoughts
are you reading the scroll who he thinks
is best fit to lead us will be a vote it
for Obamacare when he was saying oh I
really don't mean to step on your
staging but it seems like there's war
some battles are raging reporting the
news is that not our vow you know what
you're right I'll cover it now well the
wall continue YES on Twitter as planned
bowing Donald Trump and a little tin man
guy hiding his fears no sight of the end
follow it all on our app you're watching
CNN what I means while we're reading
these trivial mysteries people are dying
we're losing our liberties they're
inside our what isn't that bad inside
our hardware I understand well they
could be in your phone at this very
moment yes Pokemon's
this town's Pokemon going push expensive
beer how Hoppy's the taste for read
Zakaria hook copy and paste look I
really just think that there's stuff
that we missed like holy crap is that
true
does that list exist cover the news
shake up the ranks the real news thanks
well it's a hidden document upon which
fates sway a fortune cookie fortunes
who's writing those less a man with no
parachute just took a dive in today's
most newsworthy instance of one flung
from the sky business tough sir forgive
the belittling rome is engulfed and
we're sitting here fiddling executive
orders economy stuttering these are the
stories we're sitting here covered as
war in afghanistan hurt in iraq you need
$5 footlongs for turkey this bad as mike
breaking news the war on whistleblowers
continued today and will update the
condition of that little league referee
plus it took the Olympics by storm but
what is it like to cup someone Josh
Duggar is in the studio